a unos pocos kilómetros de la primera
línea artillería sacude al campo hacer y
cada día estos habitantes se reúnen para
observar la batalla desde la cima de una
colina y creemos en nuestro presidente
estamos junto a él así que tenemos que
pelear allí iremos
es la misma expresión de orgullo
nacional que se escucha en todas partes
en un país que prepara a sus niños para
la guerra uno de los hombres abre las
puertas de su casa en la que construyó
un refugio apresuradamente
este es nuestro refugio nos escondemos
aquí mi familia mis hijos mi esposa mi
madre nos metemos aquí y salimos cuando
el seguro lo usamos todos los días todas
las casas en este pueblo tienen refugios
como éste
esa fuerte detonación indica que las
fuerzas armadas de azerbaiyán
están disparando cerca
pero a pesar del peligro algunos se
rehúsan a escapar incluso esta mujer de
97 años
no nos vamos a ningún lado no hay duda
de eso
en la principal ciudad cercana a la
gente dice que los negocios están mal
muchos clientes se mantienen fuera de
las calles pero en esta panadería los
hornos están llenos y el personal está
trabajando a pleno
atendemos a cualquiera que venga aquí
pero también enviamos pan a la primera
línea a nuestros soldados les quieren
hacer
horneamos para ellos y los alimentamos
como madres y tías consideramos que es
nuestro deber
en cámara nadie expresa ninguna duda o
temor